seems all's well between Kim Kardashian
and Kanye West I'm just rolling with it
and it is what it is the source tells
E.T the reality star doesn't have a
problem with her ex's new love Bianca
sensory who married the rapper in a
private but unofficial ceremony in
January
ET is also learning how Kim feels about
Bianca hanging around their four
children North Saint Chicago and solemn
people don't see the context behind it
adding that Kim ultimately wants Connie
to be at peace so if Bianca helps with
that then it's fine I really want to be
active for my kids they do have
you know a family that I have to just be
positive and get it together for
et's Insider says the former couple are
still having some back and forth
arguments co-parenting healthily is the
main goal which is the primary focus for
Kim we have different views sometimes we
have different things you know it's hard
it's like co-parenting it's really hard
you know it's something Kim opened up
about back in December during a chat on
Angie Martinez's IRL podcast I feel free
in the sense
that I am not anybody else
I don't hold anyone else's
thoughts opinions burdens
and I used to hold this guilt that I
wasn't there
to fix situations and I wasn't there
to put it all back together is it a
conscious thing to um not talk about it
or to
uh
I don't know I feel like and this could
just be my assumption is that you
protect your kids
I definitely protected him and I still
will in
the eyes of my kids for my kids so in my
home my kids don't know anything that
goes on on the outside world as for
Kim's love life et's learning she will
date again one day and she's more open
to it at this point what are all the
possibilities that can happen what's my
life gonna look like yeah the a-lister
is looking for someone that adds to her
life why not
[Music]